el aborto legal en méxico sigue siendo
una meta perseguir la decisión de la
corte suprema de justicia del pasado 7
de septiembre sentó un precedente
histórico y legal para el país al
despenalizar la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo a partir de ahora no se
podrá sin violar el criterio de la corte
y la constitución procesar a mujer
alguna que aborte en los supuestos que
ha considerado válido este tribunal
constitucional de los 32 estados
mexicanos sólo 4 han legalizado el
aborto hasta las 12 semanas de gestación
sin ninguna causal la ciudad de mexico
fue la primera en sumarse en 2007 le
siguieron oaxaca en 2019 y finalmente
hidalgo y veracruz en 2021 en el resto
del país está despenalizado por
violación y en algunos estados por
condiciones de riesgo para la persona
gestante y malformaciones genéticas
graves del feto pero el tema sigue
siendo polémico méxico es un país en su
mayoría conservador y la iglesia
católica tiene una gran influencia
convocando marchas en rechazo a las
decisiones de la de suprema que según
ellos abre la posibilidad al aborto
legal en todo el país de la muerte no es
una alternativa la muerte ha sido
impresora destrucción se estima que cada
año un millón de mujeres realiza abortos
clandestinos en méxico actualmente más
de 200 mujeres están en la cárcel por
abortar bajo el agravante de homicidio
en razón de parentesco sin embargo la
despenalización del aborto no implica
que el estado regule el servicio para
que la práctica sea segura